le département de la réunion vos
nouvelles pour la deuxième année
consécutive ces résidences d'artistes un
dispositif de soutien à la création
artistique et à la valorisation du
patrimoine réunionnais une dizaine
d'artistes prendra donc résidence
pendant six mois dans les sites
patrimoniaux du département et pourront
ainsi créer leur oeuvre en résonance
avec l'histoire culturelle de leur
résidence
on reste pouvait sur les projets des
artistes parce que je le répète il ya de
la danse il y a des projets sur la
biodiversité
il ya des projets sur la musique il y a
des projets sur la peinture sur
l'expression dont il ya vraiment des
projets qui couvrent toutes les formes
de l'art mais quand même nous sommes
dans l'année les 170 en abolissant
l'esclavagé et c'est normal qu'on ait
ouvert un focus sur ce thème
les artistes bénéficieront d'une bourse
de création ainsi qu'une prise en charge
des frais qui sont dié et résidences
impliqueront également dans une démarche
d échange et de partage avec le public
ce que j'ai créée avant lazare rs la
fiction
hélas être dans ce dieu et ben je tousse
à des mondes à des émotions qui sont qui
ont été réelles a une vraie histoire et
ça me donne
ouais c'est chasser ça me charge en tant
qu'artiste et ça me permet de parler
autrement de ce que de ce qui me touche
en général a permis aux équipements
culturels de diversifier notre offre
culturelle envers les publics
ça donne à voir une autre façon une
autre vision de l'histoire le l'objectif
c'est vraiment de tous le plus de monde
possible c'est d'élargir vraiment notre
public et de faire connaître finalement
plus grand nombre l'histoire du lazaret
dix sites départementaux qui font partie
du patrimoine culturel de la réunion
offriront à leur public une dimension
nouvelle
la découverte des étapes et des
processus de création d'une oeuvre
artistique
[Musique]